hey everyone eric voss here in the new
rockstars blue dungeon
and here i am going to react to the new
amazing
wanda vision trailer this show is gonna
be the first on marvel space for slate
coming january 15th because this was all
coming out super fast on the disney
investor day conference i didn't have
time to
set up all this good stuff you get to
see my raw
reaction to it in the moment at my desk
then once you're done with that you're
gonna come back with me here we're gonna
talk about some initial first thoughts
we had of this some things to look
forward to in the next couple weeks when
this thing finally comes into our lives
and then uh later this weekend i will be
breaking down this trailer frame by
freaking frame to find all the
interesting details about wanda in
vision that
big ol yellow rock that's somehow still
back in his head anyway uh here
check out my reaction
so what's a single girl like you doing
rattling around this big howl
well i assure you i'm married to a man a
human one
[Music]
oh i don't think that was ever in
question
we just don't know what to expect
howdy neighbors hey buddy
wanda what's up who are you
i don't know
[Applause]
i think something's wrong here
this is our home then let's fight for it
[Music]
well i think we handled that well
all right uh one division trailer woof
uh this is a show that is happening
um as always with one division my
general excitement for this series is
not necessarily the different classic
sitcoms they're referencing but
the darkness that lies beneath it right
what is the deeper darker conspiracy
who is doing this to wanda is she doing
it to herself what does it mean
how is it going to connect to the
broader mcu sure i'm interested to read
these articles about how they used dick
van dyke's advice and then they used a
live audience and
they uh hammed up their performances ah
cool
i don't really give a [ __ ] i i wanna
know
what is going on here so the second half
of the trailer
is always more interesting to me but
right away at the top of this trailer we
see
these kind of colorful uh rgb glitches
as this screen opens up from this
transition to this sitcom house and we
know this is an ersatz reality because
initially they don't have wedding rings
and then she taps her finger and then
both of them
do um i did a bit better than vision
with the ring i put on my girl but just
saying
vision sucks so yeah we're seeing
references to
uh classic black and white sitcoms like
i love lucy the dick van dyke show but
we're also seeing
um later decades it comes like the brady
bunch like family ties maybe full house
maybe roseanne and uh yeah there are
lots of easter eggs on all these
surfaces
little little interesting details that
i'm sure i'm gonna find when i go
through this frame by frame that video
is gonna be coming later this weekend
but already we're seeing glitches of how
this is a false reality the
mobile over the baby's crib comes to
life with butterflies
and there is this fascinating moment
where through this intercom
wanda hears a voice of someone from the
outside saying wanda
help let us help you who is doing this
to you
which is fascinating this means that
sword is there to help wanda they're not
there to
imprison her or to contain her or try to
study her or maybe try to study her
but really they're just trying to
control the situation wanda is being
manipulated controlled by some darker
cosmic force
again we don't see mephisto in the flesh
in this but he
is suspect number one on my list the
satan from beneath the surface
a devil figure that might have shown up
in that loki trailer check out my
reaction on that because i think we may
have spotted him there
mephisto in those west coast avengers is
the demonic entity that is controlling
wanda using illusions of her kids in
order to trick her
into some coming to his power so that he
can steal
her chaos energy and with that are these
wonderful moments from monica rambo from
agnes where they look terrified they're
like
you put us here help us break free of
this
let us know what is the dark reason that
we're here
everyone in this looks terrified and i
love it i especially love this neighbor
who is just putting up her laundry but
looks like she's just being puppeted i
think this is a woman from the haunting
of hill house hunting a blind manor the
creepy ghost woman who came out of the
lake in the season two there's people in
hazmat suits this is pure government
conspiracy
and i love this idea that after a while
wanda and vision
don't want this illusion to end they say
let's fight for this
isn't that tragic and beautiful because
it's probably a
fake trap set up by mephisto or whoever
it is
to try to cross over into the world of
living but this
brief transitory moment that wanda and
vision
are allowed to live together again with
vision alive they're
fighting for that dream that probably
will end at some point
i'm getting a lot of vibes of eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind of two
figures who are projected
in a an illusory reality but they are
running
from that erasure and just trying to
cling on to each other
before the dream ends and they have to
wake up to reality and i think that's
the deeper meaning of using the monkey's
daydream believer in here
the lyrics cheer up sleepy jean oh what
can it mean that
to a daydream believer and a homecoming
queen
the daydream believer being vision who
is
just a figment of a daydream trying to
believe and the homecoming queen being
wanda she is the sad romantic who's
trying to dream her
perfect reality but it's tragic she's
not going to get it when she wakes up on
the other side of it so yeah i
obviously have a ton of theories about
how one division is going to set up
marvel phase four
and the multiverse set up things like
spider-man 3 and multiverse of madness
we know wanda maximoff is coming back in
multiverse of madness and we know monica
rambo is coming back
in uh captain marvel 2. so there's a lot
that's being set up here i'm gonna break
this down frame by frame i'm gonna find
the deeper easter eggs that are being
hidden here trust me
uh oh and yeah i'm wearing our
mandalorian this is a way shirt i'm
sorry i'm a little off-brand but
when wanda vision comes out we're gonna
have a limited edition shirt that is
going to be specific to one division
it's just going to be out and we're only
going to make a certain amount of them
once we're out we're out so check out
new rockstarsmerch.com we have a ton of
great options on there
and yeah be sure to check out my
reaction of the lookie trailer my
reaction of the falcon winter soldier
trailer my reactions of everything
coming out from this conference and all
my in-depth easter egg breakdowns that
are going to come out on the channel
over the coming days subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me at ea boss follow the rockstar
see you next time bye
[Music]
so
you